the program is that right
um yeah you can try either one i'd i'd
suggest
sharing the application yeah does that
work yes
uh if you just bring it to full screen
looks good
all right can we see it in full screen
mode
is it not um oh no it's not yet oh shoot
one second
so it's full screen for me i i'm not
sure
um and maybe let's try the reverse maybe
try sharing your desktop and then um
doing that
okay while we are playing with the full
screen or not i mean it's good that we
at least it's like okay
excellent i think yes yes
so it's great that we have andy because
probably you all
remember when we have a very nice talk
about zygust from
rajiv and he prays very much like oh if
you want to use
great solver for cyclists you should use
cbc4
and the person who if i have ever
questioned about
seigus and cbc4 it's exactly andy
reynolds
and i'm happy that he's here so andy
right now
is a research scientist at university of
iowa
before that he was a postdoc at uh
epfl and before that he also did a phd
with jesus
nelly in iowa and as they said like he's
the
person behind cbc for psychics if you
ever have any questions
ask andy and handy i hope you don't hate
me for saying that because probably not
we'll have
many uh questions and uh emails so
thank you andy um
yeah so uh my talk is syntax guided
synthesis and smt a view from inside the
solver
so i'll try to give you a bit of an
inside look into
how cbc 4 works for scigis
so smt solvers as many of you know have
many applications including software
verification
synthesis and the list goes on
so uh in this talk i'll be uh describing
how the synthesis algorithms work
in uh cbc4 which is the uh the solver
that i've been working on
uh for about 10 years now um
so this solver is open source it's
available at this link
and this is really a really big project
it's been a joint collaboration between
university of iowa
and stanford university mostly but lots
of
external collaborators so yeah many
people to thank
cesare tonelli and clark barrett are the
project leads for the uh
the team so um
to give some setting to the kind of
formalisms i'll be using in this talk so
uh
we're interested in synthesis
conjectures of this form so there exists
some function f
for which some property p holds for all
x
and uh more specifically we're
interested in predicates where
[Music]
the background theory is something like
linear arithmetic or any of the other
theories supported by smt solvers
so this theory component kind of often
motivates you to use
an smt solver
additional additionally in in addition
to the spec here
we have a syntax and so this is the
classic
syntax guided synthesis problem
which rajiv and others popularized
recently and uh
i'd like to just go over this uh kind of
standard picture of
a counterexample guided inductive
synthesis so given a syntax and a
spec you have a solution enumerator and
a solution verifier
the enumerator uh gives uh candidate
solutions
for f and uh
it enumerates them until a the solution
verifier is able to find
that there is uh a given f
has no counter examples with respect to
the spec
and the body of these functions here are
given by the syntax
so it's a pretty common picture here so
in general the smt solver or in
traditional settings has been used as
the solution
verifier but um
in our cab 15 paper we sort of
considered a different
architecture where the solution
enumeration and verification were
kind of tightly wound together in the
smt solver
in particular in cbc4 and what this
allows is
certain synthesis algorithms that
leverage
the internal state of the s t solver
become possible
and just in general for performance
reasons
uh you often really would like a tight
integration between these two components
so in this talk i'm actually going to
give you three different flavors of
synthesis in uh cbc4 how we
how we um solve these uh synthesis
conjectures
um i'll briefly mention some internal
applications of sigis that we have for
actually making
fork better and just briefly mention
some future work
so uh given this kind of high level
picture we have this
synthesis conjecture we want cbc4 to
somehow magically solve it and give us
the solution
well as i mentioned there's actually
three different independent solvers
within
cbc4 and
the first is counter example guided
quantifier instantiation this is an idea
that we
brought up in cav 2015 and we've been
working on extensions of it
in the past few years there's also what
we call the smart enumerative solver and
the fast enumerative solver and
again you know i'm just giving some
references here to some of the papers
where we describe these
techniques and uh the best
approach to apply here depends uh on the
synthesis conjecture i'll get into you
know what kind of conjectures are given
to which one of these solvers
so just going over the three techniques
now so the first one is what we call
counter example guided
quantifier instantiation and the
intuition here
is that some synthesis conjectures are
essentially first order
um and in particular this uh is the
classic max example saying that f
x y is the maximum of x and y
and what you can do with a conjecture
like this is what's known as
anti-scolization where the outermost
function
f is pushed inwards to become a first
order variable
z and then it's in a first order form
and we know how to solve these in
in smt solvers and the techniques that
we use to solve them
are under the uh umbrella of counter
example guided quantifier instantiation
so i'm not going to get into the details
of this technique but uh
the the high level ideas is mentioned
here is that
essentially there's classic quantifier
elimination procedures
that uh typically you can phrase as
instantiation-based procedures for
first order quantified formulas with one
alternation
and from this a synthesis procedure for
single and multiplication
properties follows fairly trivially
however there's quite a few caveats here
so
first of all as i mentioned the
specification must be single invocation
so the functions to synthesize in your
problem
are applied to the list of universal
variables so this max
example works you can have multiple
functions as long as they're applied to
the same arguments
but more complicated conjectures like
saying that a function is commutative
this technique is not applicable
caveat is if syntax restrictions are
present then
this method may violate them and what we
do in practice is
a heuristic fitting of the solution that
we get from
counterexample guided instantiation to
the grammar
and third a term selection strategy must
be known for the theory so
we don't magically get a synthesis
procedure for for new theories we
actually have to do the
theory theory-specific work of
determining uh how to
to uh devise this selection strategy
so for linear arithmetic small finite
domains bit vectors
these things we know how to deal with
but more
complex theories like strings and
nonlinear arithmetic we don't
okay so given all those caveats um
a more generic way of solving synthesis
conjectures in smt solvers
we use enumerative approaches and
the first of these is what i call smart
enumerative psygis
and so um in smart and enumerative
cyclists again we have this picture of
having a conjecture and a set of syntax
restrictions but what we do is it
alternatively instead of looking at as
this as syntax restrictions we look at
the grammar as an inductive data type
and the inductive data type inductive
data types is a
theory that actually smt solvers support
so then what we do with this input
conjecture is we turn this
higher order quantification on f
we we turn it into first order
quantification on this data type which
i'm calling f
int and this is done via a deep
embedding
where it also relies on these evaluation
functions
e where this essentially maps the data
type
representation of our function to its
behavior its actual behavior on on the
integers
so then given this form of the
conjecture we're able to give this
to cbc4 and solve it
via a combination of the data types
quantifier-free theory solver plus a
sigis loop
and the idea here is that basically
models for d
correspond to candidate solutions
so um when you do this when you do any
sort of enumerative approach
it's very important to consider search
space pruning
and again the solver is going to
generate us
a stream of candidate models for d
shown here and uh yeah the most
important optimization is to only
consider terms
whose analog is unique up to theory
specific simplification
so in smt solvers we spend a lot of our
time actually
developing these simplification
techniques which i'm just writing with a
down
arrow here so the the basic idea is you
convert these
data type values into uh the
corresponding terms
and uh then you discard the ones the
terms that are
uh not unique up to theory normalization
here
so i would discard y plus one
if i had already considered one plus y
for instance
so then um just looking closer at what a
syntax
uh constraint is a blocking constraint
is in this approach
uh so the solver then deals with
clauses that look thing essentially like
this
where the clause i'm showing up
on the top here is essentially saying do
not consider solutions where d
is x plus 0. so in detail what this is
saying is
either the top symbol of d is not plus
or
the first child of d is not x or the
second child of d is not zero
now to make this efficient we actually
had to modify the
the data types decision procedure to use
what are known as shared selectors
so traditionally data types uses
selectors that are unique for each
constructor
however we share these between
constructors this
this enables clause sharing um
which is described in this hard paper
um the nice thing that you can do when
you have this sort of representation of
syntax for
constraints is you can actually
generalize them so i can reason um
you know given this example that i never
want to consider
a d where it's of the form t
plus 0 for any t and it's simple to
express this you just drop the
the middle constraint so this is what's
what we call theory rewriting with
with structural generalization this is
described in our cav
2019 paper
we also use what's known as partial
evaluation
unfolding so the
the formula at the top here is saying
when the the form
when the top symbol of d is ite its
evaluation behaves like if then else
which you can express in in a fairly
straightforward way
we can also do total evaluation where
essentially when d
is fully specified then we when
we relate its evaluation to um it's its
built-in analog
and so what this enables is essentially
the quantifier free theories
in this case linear arithmetic
is working in cooperation with data
types to do the enumeration
and we combine partial and total
evaluation unfolding
where boolean connectives and ite use
partial and
the others use total
all right um so then the third approach
that i'd like to briefly mention is fast
enumerative cyclists
and the idea is actually very simple and
[Music]
it's essentially just treating this
conjecture as a black box
we directly enumerate terms based on
highly optimized uh
iterator data structures now the
pseudo code for for this approach
actually can just be described
in about five or six lines of pseudo
code
there's a lot that goes into to making
this efficient
but um the general idea is
here is to to just use a lightweight
data structure for
for enumerating terms from the grammar
as fast
as possible now
um with respect to smart enumeration
there are a couple pros of using fast
so we can still take some of the
optimizations from smart enumeration
like discarding
terms that are not unique up to theory
rewriting
and the other pro is that fast
enumeration is
indeed very fast now if you actually
compare a lightweight data structure for
enumerating
terms you get roughly 100 times the
throughput
with respect to smart enumeration
so that means it's considering roughly
100 times more candidates per second
and the reason for that is just you know
using a sat solver to to generate
candidate solutions versus
using custom iterators it's
you know a heavy hammer versus a light
hammer
uh the main con though when using uh
fast enumeration is you cannot
easily generalize syntactic constraints
and some of these more advanced
techniques for pruning the search space
are not easily applicable
and the reason for that is essentially
sometimes you need a constraint solver
to to really solve you know
navigating a search space
but uh the the summary is in fact fast
enumeration
is usually better for most of the
um sigis comp benchmarks however
when you're really dealing with
difficult problems you should use
a smart enumeration generally so in
particular for invariant synthesis
problems we almost always use smart
if you really wanted to get into the
guts of you know what what
keeps me up at night is you know this is
uh
some profiling information about how
to optimize uh fast enumerative sigis
and um just this is kind of giving the
lifetime of a term
through um
through fast enumeration so considering
a search space of about 10 million terms
we generally construct about 100 000 of
them and
look at the rewriter of those we
consider only about sixty thousand
um to evaluate on examples
uh fifteen thousand we may check against
the conjecture and so on
and uh the takeaway here is actually
that evaluating terms on concrete
examples is surprisingly the bottleneck
um when it comes to when you're really
getting down into
um what is the bottleneck for a new root
of sigis so in fact about 70
of the runtime is just evaluating terms
on concrete examples
so i'm just summarizing here the uh
the three solvers so this is what cbc4
does when it gets a conjecture
if the formula is single in location no
grammar restrictions and we know how to
solve it via quantifier instantiation
then we use the first method
if the conjecture has multiple functions
to synthesize our grammar with boolean
connectives we use smart enumerative
otherwise we use fast enumerative so
that's
uh cbc4 straight out of the box no
command line options that's
exactly what it'll do
and yeah i don't have time to to get
into uh other techniques but there's
quite a few other things that are
implemented on top of what i mentioned
for um cbc4 this includes um some of the
divide and conquer stuff
uh that uh rajiv i think uh
mentioned in his talk um
we also have a fmcad paper that has a
different
unification algorithm that
we found was helpful we also use
theory specific constant repair which i
i believe
elizabeth is going to be talking about
as well as a few other techniques that
uh i'll skip
so um ongoing work
one of the things i think is really cool
is um
that syntax guided synthesis has in fact
uh
had a lot of uses internal to our group
so
the other cbc4 developers they they all
kind of
take um take our saiga solver and apply
it internally to to do really cool
things
so this is uh this includes statically
designing
new uh quantifier instantiation
algorithms we've we've used this saiga
solver to help us do that
discovering new rewrite rules you can
use zygas to do that
test case generation is another obvious
application of sigis that we've taken
advantage of
and yeah another kind of big
research area is taking enumerative
zygus and actually applying it
the other way to to use as
an instantiation strategy for first
order formulas
so we have a tacos paper about that um
we also are working on many algorithms
that
uh utilize enumerative sigis as a black
box
so um doing things like invariant
synthesis
abduction interpolation optimization you
know
smt solvers are kind of gaining more and
more features
and sigis has been kind of a
powerful tool internally for us
and yeah in addition to all the
high-level stuff there's still
you know work to be done at the low
level um optimizing the solver
so um thanks uh thanks for the
invitation and um thanks for listening
so these techniques i mentioned in the
talk are all available in cbc4
and in fact we're working on a new
version of
cbc4 to be called cbc5
[Music]
we have a python and c plus plus apis
for scigis
and uh we're working on a java api as
well again it's open source so
thanks thank you thank you andy
thank you so do we have
time for a question we have time for
maybe one or two short questions
let me see is there anything in the chat
uh russ
please uh andy uh great talk thank you i
wish we had
more time to go into more details
one question was why you cannot
or don't want to integrate evaluation on
examples
into the actual constraint solving
that does the pruning and evaluation
i think that uh whatever slide is best
yeah yeah
so yeah i should say um this point
uh it does incorporate the evaluation
by examples now now what i'm um
what i say that you can't do is you
can't easily express
things like i don't want to consider
this shape of
of a term because maybe i did some more
advanced learning
right because to do that you would have
to modify your
your iterator to to somehow you know
navigate through shapes um
if that makes sense
i think in the examples where you spend
70 percent of your time i assume that
was input output examples right are we
talking about the same thing
yeah yeah so so we we do
the fast enumerator does skip based on
equivalence up to examples right
so in fact that's that's what this 60 is
it's actually spending most of its time
uh checking whether a term is unique up
to
uh examples let's see
uh that do you rather you have a
question and uh
please yes
you're muted
yeah so so the question uh was related
to what russ
was uh asking so how do you plan to
improve uh
bottleneck yeah so
i mean that's right so well
i i think first thing to to note is that
we
it's it's very important to have an
evaluator that
that operates on very low i mean c plus
plus data structures you don't want to
go through an api for this
so um once you once
you know your evaluator is as optimized
as
as possible then the only way to to
really improve runtime is to decrease
these the number of terms you you
consider
now uh one way to do this you know an
easy way to do this would be to make
your rewriter
more more effective because if if you
can show a term is
uh not um unique based on rewriting then
that saves you the trouble of
of having to evaluate it
so that's what essentially this i don't
know if you can see my pointer but
essentially i'm pushing i'm trying to
push down
uh the number of terms i i
evaluate but then you'll you'll get to a
line where your
if your rewriter is perfect there's just
so many
you know logically unique terms so it
looks like uniqueness is key here
yeah yeah but yeah i mean our basically
our rewriter
um you know we you know
some theories we've put in years of
effort into making the rewriter
um you know as um
uh normalizing as possible
so yeah thanks a lot very nice talk
thank you
thank you andy and i hope you will
continue to participate in this
seminar of every every monday so i have
another
question i know we always want to take a
short break
but it would maybe make sense to follow
up with andy stock with the
mark stock because it's a short five
minutes talk that actually says
one of potential optimizations of the
cvc4
or should we take a break and